Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to perform something that seems
like a true miracle. Oh yes, you are seeing it
correctly. This is robotic telekinesis. Moving
objects from afar. So, what is going on here?
Well, we take a human operator, who
performs these gestures, which are then
transferred to a robot arm, and then,
the magic happens. This is unbelievable!
So now, hold on to your papers, and let’s
see how well it can pull off all this!
Level 1 - Oh my, it comes out guns
blazing! Look at that! It is not a brute,
not at all! With delicate movements,
it can pick up these plush toys, or,
even rotate a box. That is a fantastic start.
But, it can do even better!
Level 2 - Let’s try to pick up those scissors.
That is going to require some dexterous hand
movements from the operator and…wow! Can you
believe that? By the time I am saying this,
it is already done. And, it can also stack
these cups, which is a difficult matter as its
own finger might get in the way. This was a little
more of a close call, but it still managed. Bravo!
So, with all these amazing tasks, what could
possibly be level 3? Well, check this out!
Yes, we are going to attempt to open
this drawer. That is quite a challenge.
Now note that it is slightly ajar to make
sure the task is not too hard for its fingers,
and, let’s see! Oh yeah! Good job little robot!
But what good is opening a drawer
if we aren’t doing anything with it,
so, here comes +1, the final boss level
- open the drawer, and pick up the cup.
There is no way that this is possible through
telekinesis. And…oh my goodness. I love it.
And note that this human has done
extremely well with the hand motions, but
is this person a robot whisperer, or can anyone
pull this off? That is what I would like to know.
And, wow! This works with other operators too,
which is good news, because this means that
it is relatively easy and intuitive to use.
So much so, and get this, that these people
are completely untrained operators. So cool!
So, now is the part where we expect the bad
news to come. So, where is the catch? Maybe
we need some sinfully expensive camera gear to
look at our hand to make all this happen, right?
Well, if you have been holding on to your
papers so far, now, squeeze those papers,
because we don’t need to buy anything crazy at
all! What we need is just one, uncalibrated color
camera. Today, this is available in almost
every single household. How cool is that!
So, if it can do that, all we need is
a bunch of training footage, right? But
wait a second…are you thinking what I am thinking?
If we need just one uncalibrated color camera,
can it be that? Yes! That is exactly right. We
don’t need to create any training data at all,
we can just use Youtube videos that
already exist out there in the wild!
In a previous paper, scientists at
DeepMind harnessed the power of Youtube
by having their AI watch humans play games,
and then, they would ask the AI to solve hard
exploration games and it just ripped through these
levels in Montezuma’s revenge and other games too.
And here comes the best part - what was even
more surprising there that didn’t just perform
an imitation of the teacher, no-no. It
even outperformed its human teacher!
Wow. I wonder if we could somehow do
a variant of that in a future paper?
Imagine what good we could do with that. Virtual
surgeries? Any surgeon could perform a life-saving
operation on anyone, from anywhere else in
the world? Wow. What a time to be alive! Now,
for that, the success rate needs to be much
closer to a hundred percent here, but still,
this is incredible progress in AI research. And
of course, you are an experienced Fellow Scholar,
so you don’t forget to apply The First Law
Of Papers here, which says that research
is a process. Do not look at where we are, look
at where we will be two more papers down the line.
And two more papers down the line, I bet this
will not only be significantly more accurate,
but, I would dare to say that even full body
retargeting will be possible. Yes, we could
move around, and have a real robot replicate
our movements. Just let the computer graphics
people in with their motion capture knowledge,
and this might really become a real thing soon.
So, does this get your mind going? What would you
use this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!